[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد اربع دول عربيه
تشارك في العرس الكروي العالمي منظر قطر
وتتوحد طموحات ومنتخبات السعوديه والمغرب
وتونس وقطر البلد المستضيف في تحقيق نتائج
ايجابيه لاسعاد الجماهيرها وجماهير الكره
العربيه عامه فازت السعوديه وتعدلت تونس
ومن بعضها المغرب في ما خسرت قطر اولى
مبارياتها هذه هي حصيله المنتخبات العربيه
بعد خوضها الدور الاول للمجموعات وكان
المنتخب السعودي فجرا واحده من اكبر
مفاجات كاس العالم ان لم تكن الاكبر بحسب
تصريحات الفيفا حيث احرص انتصارا سيخلده
التاريخ بعد ان حقق فوزا مثيرا على منافسه
الارجنتيني بنتيجه اثنين واحد في مواجهه
التي جمعتهما على ملعب روسيلا ضمن منافسات
المجموعه المنزليه الثالثه وتبقى حظوظه كل
المنتخبات العربيه ق للتاهل لدور المقبل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ايوه ايوه
[تصفيق]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من القاهره
الدكتور سعيد صادق واستاذه علم الاجتماع
اهلا بك وهنا في الاستوديو ان يطلع جاري
لاعب دولي سابق للمنتخبات التونسي اهلا
بكمين واسمح لي ان ابدا في الاستوديو معك
انيس همم هذه كاس عالم المفاجات كما قال
البعض والمفاجاه الكبيره كانت فوز المنتخب
السعودي على المنتخب الارجنتين مبدايا كيف
تبعت وكيف
يعني خاصه ببعض المباراه كيف كانت تردد
فعلك بعد المباراه
والفرحه الكبيره اعتبار يعني منتخب عربي
يقول لي صوره العرب ككل مبارايات كبيره
على جميع المستويات انت ممكن قلت مفاجاه
بحكم قناه فنيه وكنت موجوده هنا مع
الزملاء في ال في البلاتوه قلت انه
المنتخب السعودي قادر ما حبيت نقول انه
ينتصر لانه عنده كل الاليات وعنده مدرب
ذكي المدرب المباراه بتاعه منتخب سعودي
بالنسبه
متفائلين م- لم يكونوا يتوقعوا مثل هكذا
النتيجه خلينا نكون صادقين لانه هذا
الارجنتين ممثل موجود فكانت المفاجاه
كبيره والانتصار يعني حتى تعادل كان مرضي
الطرف السعودي ولكن نحن نتحدث على انتصار
ونتحدث على انتصار استحقه في الواقعه
الروح العزيمه همم كل شيء لنا في المباراه
رينا رينا عدد ميسي لكني يعني هو النقطه
الابرز الارجنتين ما كانش موجود كانت عليه
محاصره تكتكين الفريقين مباراه طيبه على
جميع المستويات نشوف انه سعودي يستحق
الانتصارعه لكن انا حبيت نقول على رده فعل
العرب يعني المفجاه الكبير انه السعاده
الكبيره للدول العربيه على اكيد فرحه
كبيره وخاصه في تونس كنا يعني كنا مع
التشجيعات المنتخب السعودي يقول لي صوره
طيبه
همم رده الفعل هذا هو كل الاحتفالات في كل
البلدان العربيه وهنا سؤالي لك دكتور سعيد
همم نحن تبعنا هذه الاحتفالات بفوز
السعوديه وحتى بتعادل تونس بتعادل المغرب
في انتظار همم مباراه قادمه لقطر كذلك
ولكن ما لفت الانتباه هو فرح وسعاده كل
البلدان العربيه سواء بالفوز او بتعادل في
مستوى الفوز فما الذي يحدث هل هناك رغم
يعني خلافاتهم بسيطه حتى وان كان على
اغنيه على فيلم على اي قصه ولكن قد تختلف
هذه الشعوب وتتفق فجاه على كره القدم كيف
يفسر ذلك
شوفي في عملين العمل الاول العالم العربي
يعني وحشو الفرحه بقى له عده سنوات مشاكل
دول
بتواجه تحديات اوضاع اقتصاديه حروب ازمات
متعطش لفرح
المونديال بتدي فرصه
العرب مشيت يلعبوا ضد بعض لا بيلعبوا ضد
دول ساعات بيبقى عندها استعلاء بتعتقد
انها اقوى من الفرق العربيه
سمعتك كثير جدا بعضهم كانوا بيقولوا طب
هننهزم كم صفر همم ونبقى حاجه كويسه فجاه
نجد وسط كل هذه الافكار همم
انها ستكون في همم معركه جديه انها تنتصر
مش انها تنهزم بشرف وتاخذ حاجه بسيطه لا
انها تغلب يعني همم قويه جدا ميسي واسماء
ضخمه جدا ما تقدريش تتحديها ومعندناش حد
يقدر يتحدى هذه الاسماء ده كان كله متوقع
هزيمه وحتى ال- الناس اللي كانت بتؤيد
الثانيه دي كانوا متخيلين بردك ان همم دي
معركه سهله جدا ومباريات سهله وحينتصروا
كالمعتاد اتفاجئوا بالموضوع ده فطبعا ده
عمل ازمه كمان لازم نخلي بالنا ان الثقافه
العربيه زي الثقافه في اي بلد في الدنيا
هل ممكن ماتش مباريات زي الدنمارك وتونس
الشعوب الاوروبيه هتقف مع تونس والشعوب
العربيه هتقف مع الدنمارك طبعا لا الثقافه
وال- كلهم حسوا ان احنا دوله واحده ان
احنا الفرقه دي مش الفرقه السعوديه ولا
الفئه التونسيه دي الفرقه العربيه هي اللي
بتنتصر فانتصابهم هو انتصار العرب كلهم
قدام التحديات والنظره الفوقيه اللي بعد
هذه الدول علينا طبعا ده شيء كان مهم جدا
احنا شوفنا كل الناس كانت فرحانه ازاي انا
شفت بعض
المشجعين ال- الجزائنين بيؤيده النصر او
التعادل العمليات المغرب ده رقم الخلافات
سياسيه يعني كان ممكن لو احنا الدول دي
بتلعب مع بعض ده ممكن تلاقي مشاكل لكن لما
بيلعبوا مع ابن العم يعني انا انا واخويا
على ابن عمي وانا وابن عمي الغريب لما
بنلعب بقى مع ابن العم
مع بعض دكتور سعيد صحيح
همم بعض الانواع ولكن همم هو السؤال يتطرح
كيف لهذه النفسيه ان تتغير ان تنسى هذه
الخلافات وان تشجع وان تفرح لفرحي من كان
يوما ما على اختلاف مع يعني هل يمكن
الحديث على قوميه العربيه ولو انها كانت
هناك انتقادات عزيزه على هذا المصطلح ربما
المعطي يدعموها البعض ينتقده ولكن هل هناك
احساس عروب بلازا موجود تعتقد
اعتقد ان
التعاطف العربي ال الجماعي اكد الهويه
العربيه اكد ان احنا مش منفصلين مش دول
منفصل عن بعضها لا ده احنا اللي بيحصل في
المغرب اللي بيحصل في تونس اللي بيحصل في
السعوديه هو يمس العالم العربي كله هي لما
تنتصر السعوديه العالم العربي انتصر لما
بتتعادل تونس او المغرب العالم العربي كله
همم حس بقوته زادت الحماس عند العرب
وامكانيه ان هم يغلبوا وينتصروا في هذه
المونديال نعمل ناس فاكرين ان العرب دول
حاجه ثانيه او حاجه ثالثه كمال اتعدد ما
احناش بنعمل لاعبين لا احنا ممكن نكون
لاعبين ونبقى نعمل ونعمل انتصارات كمان ان
ال- المونديال بيتعمل في ارض عربيه وداخل
المشجعين العرب اللي موجودين في دول
الخليجي يروح وده كمان ساعه اللعيبه انه
فجاه عنده جمهور وموجود تخيل لو المونديال
ده معمول في الارجنتين كم واحد عربي كان
انما لما بتعمل في قطر او يتعمل في اي
منطقه عربيه
جدا
لاعب نسترجع معك بعض الذكريات لنفهم كذلك
كيف يحدث هذا التغير في مزاج اللاعب قبل
المشاهد بمعنى انه انتم كذلك على الارض
على ارض الميدان هناك مشحنات همم حتى وان
كانت امام فرق عربيه اخرى ولكن اول ما
يخرج اللاعب من الميدان وكانه هناك علاقه
صداقه متينه بينكم فكيف يفسر ذلك هو
النقاط والفوز هو الهدف كل منتخب كل فريق
كل لاعب عنده اهداف اليوم نحكي على
منتخبات عند اهداف ثانيه قات هو المرور
للدوره الثانيه وهذا مهم جدا لكن ممكن
الجمهوري انه المنافسه على الميدان بتكون
خارج الميدان بالعكس اليوم عندنا اصدقاء
من الدول الكل نفس اللاعبين اللي يكون انت
تمارس مع في مباراه تشيل 90 دقيقه وفيها
يعني كما نقول احنا حرب عصا في تشنج فيها
كذا لكن بعد المباراه كل شيء كره القدم 90
دقيقه بالنسبه لنا بعد 90 دقيقه نرجعوا عن
علاقات مع الدول كل ما عديد اللاعبين حتى
الاوروبيين نصور انا كره قدم مرايتي لما
تفرقش هي الفرحه لكن هناك
اليوم انت سوري يجيبه معك الجميع
كل هذه الجماهير العربيه من كل الدول تدعم
فريق عربي معين الى اي مدى هذا يمثل حافظ
للاعب لما يتابع لاعب السعودي مثلا كان
فرحه الدول العربيه بفوز السعوديه على
الارجنتين الى اين ذه هذا يمثل حافز كذلك
اشكيك في انه دوله قطر تنجم الدعم
المونديال كبير
بعد جو شافوا عروض كبيره وكبيره جدا شوفوا
حاجات يعني من طراز عالي على جميع
المستويات من بنيه تحتيه من الميادين يعني
كل شيء متوفر بتكون كاس عالم كبيره برشا
بعد الشراره بدات من مقابله السعوديه
الاداء والتحفيز واللي شفناه في منتخب
سعودي وضربه الشهراني يعني نشوف في تونس
اللي هي ممكن عندي فكره نوعا ما يفش
الجمارك مع الاصابه بتاع الشهراني
قيمه ال- ال- المونديال ريت اليوم
يعني هدومه العربيه
مثل كل العرب وهذيك الصوره العرب لانه همم
هناك يعني تقسيم برغم منه واحنا عندنا كل
امكانيات النجاح قصه فنيه كسوه يعني في
التنظيم يعني هذه اكبر دليل هو المونديال
هذه اللي يعطيها فرصه وله غدوه نشوفه دوله
اخرى عربيه تنظم كاس عالم
ممكن نعمل ساعه في الدور الثاني ان كان
هناك مرور لادوار اخرى ان شاء الله نتمنى
لكل همم
الفرق العربيه ولكن دكتور سعيد باختصار لو
سمحت لي هذا الدعم العربي لما يتوحد خلف
لاعب عربي او خلف فريق عربي كيف يمكن ان
يدعمه ان يحفزه من الناحيه نفسه
طبعا لما بيجد انه مش بيحمل فقط عالم بلده
انما بيحمل اعلام ال 22 دوله عربيه طبعا
ده يعني ضغط عليه
وحافز قوي انه لازم يكون الاداء بتاعه
اداء قوي جدا اداء جاد انه لن يعني ما
نقللش من ايه من قوه الخصم ولا نبال في
قوتنا لكن لازم نلعب بطريقه جد حتى لو
بتهزني هتلاقي الناس بتحس انك انت لعبت
بالشرف لعبت بجدديه عملت كل جهدك فهيبقى
طبعا الناس هتحترمك اكثر ده كمان هيخلي
الاخر بره ينظر لنا نظره مختلفه عن
النظارات التقليديه
او في تشجيع هذه المباريات يمكن ان ينسحب
على الشعوب لفتره طويله امنحل نتحدث على
وحده المؤقته باختصار وب
لا ممكن لو انت بنيتي الاعلام العربي انه
يبني يركز على الايجابيات والعلاقات
الطيبه بين اصحاب العربيه بعيد عن
الخلافات السياسيه طبعا
علم الاجتماع والشكر كذلك للاعب ادول سابق
لمنتخب تونس انيس العقاريه السلام عليكم